بعد المباراة في غرفة خلع الملابس ،
لم يتمكنوا حتى من الاحتفال بها لأنها في
الواقع لأننا
لم نتمكن من الحصول على المزيد من سلاسل
التمريرات في ميونيخ التي
تساعدنا على الراحة مع الكرة
ولم نرتاح كثيرًا مع الكرة و  لقد
ركضوا كثيرًا
وأن
القوة كانت صعبة وتصور
المواسم السابقة التي قمت بالتناوب عليها كثيرًا
ولم تكن جيدة ويجب أن
أفكر في الأمر ولديهم
الكثير من الشكوك حول
التشكيلة لأرى أنني يجب أن أرى
جلسة التدريب  اليوم وأتحدث مع العديد منهم
قليلًا منهم وانظر ما هو شعوري
بالطبع هم سيحرمونني من ذهابي أريد
اللعب أريد أن ألعب
وهذا أمر مؤكد أنه من الصعب
العثور على مكان وأنا لا أفعل.  تريد أن تلعب
ولكن في نفس الوقت
علينا أن نتأكد من أن الناس
ليسوا
في الحد الأدنى من الظروف كما تعلم أن الأمر لا يتعلق
فقط بما
تعرفه كانت
هذه اللعبة لأننا جئنا من العديد من العديد
من الألعاب كل
ثلاثة أيام أربعة  أيام ثلاثة أيام لأيام
مع الكثير من الألعاب ومعرفة ذلك أه
إذا خسرنا سنخرج وهنا
التعب العقلي وهو
كبير لذا
عليك أن نرى علينا أن نرى
يجب أن أنتظر